president biden making some bizarre
comments about gun control as he says he
does not think we need to harden schools
it's been one week since the horrific
events in uvalde texas where a teen
gunman went on a rampage inside a
classroom killing 19 students and two
teachers the president says the country
needs to act but so far he hasn't even
talked to congress about solutions
and democrats so far don't seem
interested in republican proposals like
boosting school safety or addressing
mental health
instead biden's attacking the most
popular handgun for self-protection
listen
a 22-caliber bullet
will lodge in a lung a nine-millimeter
bullet blows the lung out of the body
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is that
there's simply no rational basis for it
in terms of
about
self-protection hunting the constitution
the second amendment was never absolute
in the white house trying to clean up
what joe meant
while saying he doesn't believe in
hardening schools
he supports a ban on sale of assault
weapons and high capacity magazines and
expanded background checks to keep guns
out of the dangerous hands he does not
support a ban on the sale of all
handguns to answer your questions i know
there's been a conversation about
hardening schools that is not something
that he believes in
and vice president kamala harris
offering up one of her signature word
salad responses while calling for an
assault weapons ban
i will say as i said countless times we
are not sitting around
waiting to figure out what the solution
looks like you know we're not looking
for a vaccine
we know what works on this
it includes let's have an assault
weapons fan an assault weapon is a
weapon of war
with no place
no place in a civil society
greg so the president is not supporting
hardening schools
after you saw what we saw last week
just out of pure tactical reasons why
going into a negotiation when you say
yeah let's put hardening schools on the
table let's deal i'll explain to you
what's wrong with his thinking and the
answer to this if you want a solution
that you can trust the person that is
venturing this this solution has to have
more than one variable or you don't
trust them so if you have if you're a
single variable thinker which is what
democrats are about guns that means that
everything they say will be guns that's
their ideological cause no one can trust
them because they know what their answer
is going to be it's always going to be
guns guns guns and we know that maybe
that rifle the accessibility of that
rifle plays a role in the in the in the
role of this mass shooting because the
person got a hold of it and used it all
right but you end up in this idiocy
where where biden finds himself where
he's banning just common handguns and
dismisses hardening targets which is it
only makes sense if you were clinging to
one variable in kind of his feeble brain
and this is why gun control dies because
you can't trust the people who are
pushing this this forward the solution
should tackle three variables
should be more than a gun control issue
right you should look at social media
mental health how are schools addressing
mental health and then you can look at
the guns i'm i would be totally
interested in raising the the age to 21
for this rifle if it was done
not as a law but as an experiment right
six years try it out compare it to the
previous six years it's hard to get
variables uh out of this because
mass shootings are even though they're
not rare enough they are rare you can go
for six years without any right but the
point is you got to treat it not like a
law but like a test because then that
removes the uh the what he called the
slippery slope thing like oh my god
what's next and then you could also do
the same thing with social media age
minimums because that would be really
interesting to look at too and then you
could look at better mental mental
health services at schools
why aren't we testing all of these
things it's because we get stuck in this
single variable thinking where you have
this the leader of the free world saying
absolute gibberish because he can't
leave his this is a single idea prison
he can't get out of it
yeah that's right can't get out of his
own prison
judge i've been there yeah
usually they don't have they don't like
cash bail so it should be pretty easy
for him to walk judge when you hear the
president say you know maybe we can work
with the republicans on this and then
utters out this gibberish about banning
handguns and nine millimeter handguns
well look why would you deal with a guy
like that well no but but this is the
guy who said i'm going to unite everyone
i'm going to be the adult in the room
we're going to make this work no he
doesn't want to make it work he needs
something to up his numbers so he comes
out with an idea he goes in his corner
and that's basically the end of it this
is what i'm going to do and i don't want
to do anything else and all you
republicans just want to work with me
let me just say a couple of things does
removing guns
limit the number of crimes i would like
you to look at what's going on in the
city of chicago which just this past
weekend there were nine people killed
and i think there was something like i
don't know 40 shot in chicago
guns are illegal in chicago
so you really have to look at when is
the last time we analyze this stuff the
last time we had a ban on assault
weapons i remember i was a sitting d.a i
was in favor of it and then we found out
that there was no discernible change in
crime when we banned assault weapons now
let's look at california crime is going
up shootings are going up whether you're
talking about compton los angeles any of
these places and it's where this you
have the toughest gun laws in the
country
so the vast majority and people need to
understand this of crimes that are being
committed are being committed by people
who have illegal weapons and this is a
stat less than two percent of all
prisoners had a firearm obtained from a
retail source at the time they committed
their crime so stop with this background
check and all that but if you want to
let's come together on that you want to
come together on that maybe let's do it
let's make a deal but this guy is too
simple to make a deal i have a couple
more things the constitution this is his
second amendment freedom of speech
freedom of religion and this guy is so
ditzy he said you couldn't buy a
cannonball when they passed the second
amendment he is so limited in his
historical references there is nothing
that prevented anyone from buying a
cannonball when they wrote the
constitution and my last comment is this
the gun related deaths that we're
talking about are not only the most of
them in cities where gun crimes are
illegal
but they're also in cities where we've
got individuals who can get guns who are
part of gangs and in the end half of the
gun crimes are suicides and that's all i
have to say why won't he put mental
health on the table here's
jessica
mental health is a conversation that
democrats are having non-stop and it's
republicans who to greg's point are
things very well-minded but not about
this single variable-minded like in
texas where greg abbott has voted
against mental health expansion he's
doesn't want to have medicaid expansion
also which would make sure that the
poorest people have access have access
to mental health resources democrats
will
never not have a conversation with you
about these other issues they will also
talk about the specifics of what
happened and you want to talk about
chicago that's a different block we're
going to talk about chicago we need to
talk about school shootings that are
carried out with ar-15s we had 400 000
ar-15s that were owned by americans
between 19 and 1994. today there are 20
million dan crenshaw was being
interviewed the congressman about
whether we have a gun problem here we
have 300 million people and 400 million
guns if the founding fathers were around
today do you think they would have said
we we did this yes so people can have
more than one gun people can have eight
guys fifteen guys you don't say yes you
don't you don't speak for the founders
when you don't
it's an absolute
in 1994 when we got the assault weapons
ban we did have the kind of data then
that greg is talking about you want to
say put it in for six years we know that
the number of mass shootings were
lowered by 43 percent then it was
allowed to sunset by george w bush this
is something that can be done again
people do not need this for just walking
around
it's unnecessary and kids are dying
because of it and there were 19 cops
standing in the hallway i hear all the
time there's nothing more valuable than
a good guy with a gun there were 19 good
guys with guns that stood in the hallway
as kids were still caught
people at home who are going to say guns
don't kill people people kill people but
access to guns allows them to hold on so
what about the red flag laws i find the
more republicans i speak to the more
openness there is in some parts of the
country to the red flag laws when you
talk about bringing back moral values
which many republicans are doing in the
wake of this you have to talk about the
fact that you're talking about glacial
change people want to know what could
have prevented a shooting like this
could red flags laws have helped the
wall street journal wrote a piece red
flag laws are good as good as the data
basically pointing out that this was a
person who broadcast over private
messaging on facebook which facebook has
said that he was going to go kill his
grandmother and that he was going to go
shoot up in elementary school that data
the wall street journal points out is
only private to those he wanted that
private from how about the social media
companies accountability and in tracking
that kind of conversation over social
media maybe there's some bipartisan
support for these red flag laws that
could identify an unsteady person that
owns a gun legally or illegally we
actually tried this i mean donald trump
who was a new york liberal before he was
a republican president was for gun
control and he tried with the bumping
bump stocks and red flag laws and fellow
republicans told him it will not flag
laws didn't work in buffalo so and i i
actually think 19 states
dead cats
don't sell them a gun if you got a bag
of dead cats cause i think we can agree
on that sure all right where did that
come from the guy was holding up a bag
of dead cats oh i didn't know yeah the
shooter in texas he's a psychopath and
by the way his enemies he shouldn't have
sold a gun to a guy like that has
anybody asked how he could afford those
guns how he could before
come from well the media won't pursue
that right absolutely up next president
biden trying to convince americans the
economy's good and his policies
drive us into the ditch